hey guys welcome to my new life here in
the rap massage van where I give
homeless people free bum rubs god it
smells like it's like well it smells
like your massage you'd almost be here
yeah that's exactly that's a good way to
describe it all right now look at man we
got soup kitchens places for homeless
people to eat but we don't have massage
kitchens places for massages to go down
on homeless people Carl I'm sorry but we
have an opportunity for you and it's
pressing Carl we'd like you to join us
at the exhibit concert
interested I've been thinking a lot
about what you guys said and you're
absolutely right you know trying to find
my inner peace and right now I've kind
of found it in this dude's giant back
I'm loving it I'm loving it so uh I'm
gonna have to say the nay-no my brothers
know Carl come on dude all you got to do
is pretend like you were having sex with
our co-workers wife and then he's
probably gonna beat you up just like
you've wanted
can I come I want you to come here see
this is this to do in my the dude yeah
I'm Badou homie
I'm the one who's been giving your wife
the stinky man so what are you gonna do
just punch me right here man I wanna
play bitch make him bleed
well I would like to know what was she
saying about me oh that was it was what
was she saying about me what'd she say
about you
oh dude she was saying that you have a
tiny little dick all right like a
tootsie roll man Wow I had the
Charleston chew the king-sized version
and you know your bitch has a sweet
tooth
boy referring to her emotional needs
emotion no there's nothing emotional
about a man you don't get it you can't F
right and I gave her the Dunkin donut
and then I had that bitch do in Cirque
du Soleil all over the room and she
creamed her panties for me god damn it
and guess what she called me man she
called me the King I'm King Carl say it
Mike hey King
oh say it Mike he's a king one more time
Mike any case I'm the king man and guess
what you just the Prince man you Prince
Mahon Ted Montez you a bitch okay and
that baby in your wife's stomach guess
what man that's mine dude sorry but
you're not a daddy you're not a daddy
now hit me man come on man you get first
you get number one come on okay oh Jesus
this a dildo that's a dildo guys Oh
gross man
you